bonjour père emmanuel thomann merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france alors on l'a vu la question de
l'indépendance de la justice polonaise
et la primauté du droit européen est
source de tensions entre varsovie et
bruxelles que doit-on attendre de ce
nouveau sommet européen une
réconciliation est-elle possible
donc je pense que cette crise va
perdurer parce qu'elle touche
fondamentalement une lutte de pouvoir
entre
les organisations
supranationales et les états nations en
particulier
l'union européenne qui est une
organisation supranationale et qui veut
toujours
avoir plus de pouvoir par rapport aux
états et cette dispute en réalité n'est
pas nouvelle elle et
elle se retrouve dans toutes les crises
de l'union européenne il faut se
rappeler que déjà en 2009 la cour
constitutionnelle allemande avait
déclaré que l'union européenne n'était
pas un état fédéral qui n'avaient pas de
peuple européen et donc l'union
européenne ne pouvait pas étendre sans
cesse ses compétences sans l'approbation
des états nations et la pologne vient de
répéter la même chose en réalité donc
c'est une lutte de pouvoir et qui va
perdurer et qui perdurera à l'avenir
dans parce que c'est le c'est cette
lutte s'inscrit dans deux finalités
différentes du projet européen un état
fédéral ou une europe des nations
souveraines la pologne peut compter sur
le soutien de la rendre iv est ce que
c'est suffisant pour avoir une chance de
remporter ce bras de fer face à l'union
européenne
alors je crois que l'homme justement
l'allemagne qui pousse à respect soit
disant de l'état de droit par les autres
états européens est évidemment l'état de
droit est devenu un instrument de
pouvoir pour faire fléchir les autres
états mais comme l'allemagne a eu déjà
dans le passé là sa course titus ionel
les mêmes avis par rapport à la primauté
du droit constitutionnel nationales sur
le droit européen l'allemagne ne veut
pas pousser trop loin la dispute parce
qu'elle sait très bien que sa propre
cour constitutionnelle pour à nouveau et
va à nouveau statuer va aller dans le
même sens à l'avenir donc le
la pologne et la hongrie mise à part des
des avertissements des déclarations
politiques je ne pense pas qu'ils
pourront réellement être mis en minorité
parce que l'allemagne va faire en sorte
de de pousser à la négociation et non
pas d'affrontements parce que l'union
européenne va se diviser on voit
d'ailleurs même que dans d'autres les
pays d'europe de l'ouest
et non pas les pays d'europe centrale et
orientale
dans les pays d'europe de l'ouest coop
comme la france d'ailleurs certains
européiste convaincu aussi affirmé qu'il
fallait limiter le
l'extension continue d des pouvoirs de
lire open comme michel barnier par
exemple tendance de la justice fait
débat dans d'autres pays que de l'union
européenne pourquoi pourquoi la pologne
est elle plus pointé du doigt que
d'autres états qui a il ya deux poids
deux mesures exactement yann hiérarchie
de pouvoir entre les états dans l'union
européenne
les états sont égaux en droit mais pas
du point de vue géopolitique et il faut
se rappeler que donc l'homme le projet
européen qui était initiée par la france
l allemagne dans les années 50 c'était
largy progressivement et les pays
d'europe centrale et orientale qui
appartenait au pacte de varsovie des
états qui était communiste
lorsqu'ils sont entrés dans le projet
européen
de selon leur point de vue ils voulaient
n'ont pas partagé la souveraineté comme
le proposait la france l allemagne dans
leur vision de du projet européen mais
gagner en souveraineté donc
il ya une une approche différente mais
en réalité je pense que la vision des
polonais des hongrois des pays d'europe
centrale orient à lui de préserver un
projet européen basé sur une europe des
nations est en train aussi de gagner les
esprits à l'ouest aussi en cette
dernière question rapidement à notre
sujet de tension sur la table
aujourd'hui le dossier migratoire et
notamment la tacc hybride lancée par la
biélorussie contre ses voisins européens
à quoi peut-on s'attendre
alors ok on peut s'attendre
oui des déclarations contre la
biélorussie parce que derrière cette
affaire il ya évidemment aussi une lutte
de pouvoir entre
l'union européenne et la russie avec la
biélorussie qui est l'état temps pau je
dirais pour la pour la russie et donc
les l'union européenne en femme soutient
l'opposition c'est la promotion d'un
changement de régime en réalité pour
affaiblir la russie dans la vision
euro-atlantique et c'est pour ça que
cette question d'aider les migrants
évidemment est instrumentalisée dans
cette dispute donc on peut s'attendre à
un renforcement sans doute des
frontières schengen ce que demandent
d'ailleurs la plupart des états membres
comme on l'a fait pour la grèce
vis-à-vis de la turquie merci beaucoup
pierre emmanuel thomann je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur en géopolitique et
fondateur d'euro continent euros